JEFF POSNICK: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to this week's show of
YouTube Developers Live.
I'm Jeff Posnick coming to
you from New York City.
I'm a member of the Developer
Relations team.
And this week I'm really excited
to talk to you about
different ways of customizing
the YouTube-embedded player.
Before I get started though, I
want a couple of ground rules
to just talk about what we're
going to be covering in
today's show.
There are a lot of different
embedded players, and there's
lots of ways to customize
them.
But for this particular show,
we're going to be focusing on
customizing be iframe-embedded
player, which is our current
recommended way of embedding
videos on web pages.
And we're going to specifically
focus on the
options that are most relevant
for desktop web browsers.
A lot of these customization
options we'll talk about do
have some effect with mobile
browser playback, but not all
of them do.
And we're going to just focus
today on how these options
affect desktop playback.
Another thing that we're not
going to be covering today is
using the JavaScript API for
controlling playback.
This is obviously a very
interesting topic and a very
important topic, it's just a
little bit outside the scope
of what we wanted
to talk about.
So we're not going to be
covering any of the methods
that you could use in JavaScript
to start playback
or control playback, or receive
events when playback
changes happen in the player.
What we are going to be covering
is things that are
covered in the documentation
on the specific page, so if
you pull that up, we'll
share that with you.
And as I'm going through this
demo, a lot of what I'm going
to be covering refers to
specific web pages.
When we go back and post this
video on YouTube, I'll have
annotations linking to all the
web pages, so that you could
go there and check them
out yourself.
So this is our main jumping off
point for talking about
the customization that
you could do to the
YouTube-embedded
iframe player.
And you could get here from
our main Developers.Googl
e.com/YouTubedocumentation.
And everything in this parameter
section in the docks
is fair game for what we're
going to talk about now.
One other thing before I
actually get into explaining
these parameters is explain
the two different types of
ways that you can load the
iframe-embedded player onto
your web page.
And we're kind of agnostic as
to the way in which you load
it, these parameters are going
to behave the same way
regardless.
But I just wanted to point out
that there are two different
ways of doing it.
The first way is using the
iframes kind of like YouTube
player, YT.
Player constructor.
And this is a more programmatic
way of loading
the iframe player onto
your web page.
So I have this jsFiddle right
here that demonstrates what
that will look like.
It basically involves loading
in this JavaScript API and
calling the YT.
Player constructor, and passing
in the ID of a div
that's on your page.
And you'll see here that there
is this playerVars section
that you could pass
in to the YT.
Player constructors.
So this is where you get to
specify all the options that
we're going to be covering today
if you're using the YT.
PLayer constructor.
And just quickly jumping over
here, this is where I stole
that code from in our Getting
Started guide
for the iframe API.
We talk about how you could
actually get that code.
So feel free to borrow it there
or from that jsFiddle.
The second way that you load
the iframe player onto your
page is just with a simple
iframe tag that you could add
to any web page.
And this has the same sort of
parameters that the YT.
Player constructor is,
kind under the hood.
They really end up creating
the same thing.
Just that the YT.
Player constructor is a
programmatic way of creating
this tag using JavaScript.
This is if you're just writing
out [? initiable ?]
template, or even if you're not
a JavaScript programmer at
all and just want to include
some HTML on your page, you
could use this tag.
And the same parameters we are
going to be talking about can
go at the very end of the URL
that you use as a source of
the iframe tag.
So over here we have autoplay
equals 0 and
controls equals 0.
And that corresponds to what
we're seeing over here for the
playerVars.
And the actual documentation for
using that iframe tag is
found over here.
If you look in the docs over
here, we give some examples.
So that's the ground rules for
how you actually will use
these parameters that
we are going to be
describing in your own code.
So I just wanted to run through
pretty much from the
top, all these parameters
here.
We do have really nice
explanations what they mean in
the documentation.
So it's going to be a little bit
repetitive in some cases.
But I did want to highlight some
specific ones that are
the most useful.
So autohide comes in
handy quite a bit.
This is something that controls
the behavior of the
controls, more or less, that
are on the bottom of the
YouTube Player.
It's not necessarily the initial
state of the controls,
but it's more like what happens
the controls once
playback starts.
And I'm going to demonstrate
the ways of setting those
different values by going to
this page over here, which is
our YouTube player demo.
So this is another really
great resource.
And it's an alternative to
writing this code over here or
writing this in jsFiddle.
It's just a way to play around
with these parameters in a
live setting.
And we can think of it like our
API explorer, if you've
ever used that for
our data APIs.
This is the equivalent
for our player APIs.
So what it lets you do is go
over here on the right and
start choosing different values
for the parameters.
And I'm not going to do this
for every single parameter
that we didn't talk about, but
just to show you how you could
experiment in real time
without having
to write any code.
Let me just try setting autohide
to 0 over here.
I'm going to click
Update Player.
And once I set it,
Begin Playback.
This is a very old video.
Actually, part of what I plan
on doing is replacing the
default video that we use in
this demo with this video, so
we'll have a very meta
experience, if you happen to
be watching this while on the
demo page trying out these
parameters.
So the main thing to keep in
mind though is that the
controls at the bottom
over here did not
disappear during playback.
And if I were to go over here
and change the autohide to 1,
Update Player--
it says, loading in the player
with the parameters--
you'll see that when I mouse
over, the controls are there.
When I move the mouse away,
the controls disappear.
So for experiences where you
want maybe a more of lean-back
type of situation, where people
aren't going to be
interacting with the controls,
or you don't want the controls
to overlay the video playback,
it's a very useful parameter.
Autoplay is next on the
list alphabetically.
Somewhat self-explanatory, if
you add in the autoplay
parameter, then the video will
start playing back as soon as
the iframe embed is loaded
on the page.
I'll give a quick demo
of that over here.
And this time, instead of using
the player demo page,
I'm going to use that jsFiddle
that we have set up.
And I'm going to just change
the autoplay value to 1.
I'm going to click Run.
And you could see,
here's the embed.
It started playing as soon
as the page loads.
So there are certain scenarios
where that's useful, certain
scenarios where it's not.
You have to use your judgment
as to whether autoplaying is
the right thing to do.
cc_load_policy is something that
controls whether closed
captions or subtitles are
displayed by default.
And the default behavior--
we don't set anything for
cc_load_policy--
is that the user's preferences
[? basic ?] on YouTube.
There is a way of going in and
saying whether you want closed
captions or you don't want
closed captions.
That's normally what
takes effect.
If you have a specific video and
you know that you always
want the closed captions to
be shown, you could set
cc_load_policy to 1.
Color's a bit interesting.
It's not something that I see
widely used and necessarily,
but there are some cases where
you might want a little bit of
flair, let's say,
in your player.
And you don't want the
default behavior.
So I'm going to go to the
player demo page really
quickly and just show
you what it does.
You could set color to white
instead of red, and you update
the player.
Controls should look slightly
different depending upon
whether they're red or white.
So it just basically changes the
branding a little bit on
the player.
Not necessarily the most useful
thing in the world, but
it does give you a little
bit more control.
Speaking of control, next item
alphabetically is controls.
And this is actually
quite useful.
There are cases where you can
actually see a lot of
performance benefits by changing
this value from the
defaults to a specific
option, which is 2.
We have a note in the
documentation explaining more
about what this does.
And if you read the note, it
says that controls=2 can give
you a performance improvement
over the default behavior.
And the reason why that is is
controls=2 has a way of
loading the iframe embedded
player that does not
initialize the underlying
Flash player by default.
It doesn't initialize it until
you actually click on the
video thumbnail to start
the playback.
This obviously only applies to
playbacks that do involve the
Flash player.
The iframe player might decide
that HTML5 video is going to
be used instead, in which case
this isn't quite as important.
But in situations where Flash
playback is being used, you
could really see a significant
performance benefit from
setting controls=2.
And that might be the default
that we use at some point in
the future, as mentioned here,
as soon as some UI issues are
worked out.
And I'm going to give you an
example of how you could see
that performance benefit.
It mainly comes across
when you have--
let's say, I don't want to say
a specific number, but if you
have multiple iframe embeds
on the same page.
So this one over here has--
I think there might be 50 from
the Google Developers channel.
So the first thing that we're
going to look at is behavior
pretty much by default, where
there's controls=1 or if you
leave out controls.
It's the default.
And it can take some time for
these underlying Flash players
to all initialize, and can add
some latency to the point
where things look like
they're ready to be
interacted with on the page.
So not necessarily the
best user experience.
If you take the same thing and
you change it to controls
equals 2 explicitly, then you
should see a much better
performance.
It's quite remarkable,
actually.
So what's going on?
[? You can see ?] now again,
it's just loading in these
thumbnails.
It's not initializing the Flash
player for each video.
And you could have--
I don't want to say you should
put thousands of embeds on the
same page-- but if you do happen
to have a large number
of embeds on the page, you
will see a difference.
So very important to
keep that in mind.
A few other parameters
that are not
necessarily as exciting.
There's keyboard support for
the ActionScript player.
I'm not really sure why you
would want to turn this off.
I think it's actually kind of
nice to keep it on, but we do
have the option of turning
it off if you want.
This particular parameter
is quite important, the
enablejsapi.
And what it'll let you do is
ensure that you are able to
talk to the iframe player
on the page using
the JavaScript API.
So as I mentioned, we're not
actually going to be covering
anything about the JavaScript
API in this particular
session, but plenty of
people have used it.
And the one case where you
really need to be sure you're
explicitly setting this is when
you're writing the iframe
tag directly to the page.
So kind of like this.
Because when you're
using the YT.
Player constructor, it pretty
much will be set automatically
for you by default.
Just because by virtue of the
fact that you're using
JavaScript to initialize the
player, chances are you are
going to want to talk to the
player with JavaScript.
So it always gets set for you.
But that's not the case if you
explicitly are writing an
iframe tag to a page.
So you really do need to make
sure there that you have
enabled jsapi set to 1.
And that's necessary in order to
talk to the iframe player.
The end tag, and a little
bit further down
the alphabet is start.
So these are two corresponding
tags.
This gives you a really easy way
of putting an embed on a
page that has its custom end
time and a custom start time.
So if you have a three-minute
video and you really want to
embed 30 seconds in the middle
of the video, you could use
those two tags to do it.
As soon as playback reaches
the end tag, playback will
effectively stop.
So that could be useful.
fs parameter--
not super useful anymore.
Basically, it lets you control
whether there is a full-screen
button on the ActionScript
3.0 player.
But I don't think it has an
effect on the HTML5 player.
So not really sure why you would
want to change that.
iv_load_policy is something that
controls whether, I guess
interactive video
annotations--
for lack of a better way of
describing it-- is shown on
your video by default.
So there's a couple of different
values over here.
You use 1 or 3.
Basically, setting at 1 will
make sure that those
annotations are shown.
Setting it to 3 will make
sure that they're
not shown by default.
But at any point, the user can
change the setting explicitly
in the player, if they want to
show or hide the annotations.
List is a really interesting
one.
And there is quite a bit to
talk about with list.
So I'm actually going to defer
at this point to a whole blog
post that we put together to
talk about the different types
of values that the list
parameter and the listType
parameter, which is
an associated
parameter, can take.
I'll link to this blog post in
the video annotations, so you
can read it in more detail.
But the long and short of it is
that it's a really easy way
to take a simple embedded player
on your page and use
that to display a list of videos
without having to hard
code the video IDs in advance.
So you could have one specific
player on your page and say,
play back the most recent videos
from a specific YouTube
channel or specific playlist or
specific search term, even.
So you could say, this is an
embedded player that will show
the latest videos that
match the search
from the YouTube API.
Something along those lines.
It's quite useful.
I don't think as many people
know about it as they should.
So hopefully people will watch
this and start using it a
little bit more.
listType goes hand in hand
with the list parameter.
There is a loop parameter.
And the loop parameter will--
as explained in the
documentation--
allow you to automatically
restart playback of a video
when the playback has ended.
You have to have a little bit of
a hack, if you're trying to
do this for a single video,
where you create a playlist
that has only one video
entry in it.
So we have a little bit
more info there.
modestbranding is something
that's covered in a different
blog post, which we will also
link to from the annotation.
And it talks about the option
down here at the bottom.
It's not exactly a fully
logoless player.
There still is a YouTube logo
involved that shows, I think,
on the pause screen in the upper
right-hand corner, or in
the queued screen.
But it is one parameter that you
could set to tone down the
YouTube branding
on the player.
And that's something that you
might want to keep in mind if
you have a scenario where you
want to embed, but don't want
to make it fully YouTubed.
The origin parameter is
something that can be used
when you are using the iframe
embed tag, and you're going to
be interacting with the iframe
embed using JavaScript.
So as mentioned before, you
might want to explicitly put
in enablejsapi.
You also might want to
put in the origin
parameter over here.
And you set it equal to the full
URL for your web page.
And this is a security mechanism
to make sure that
only JavaScript that's run from
your host web page is
able to talk to the player.
And if you're using the YT.
Player constructor, it gets
set automatically for you.
So this is another instance
where you really only have to
worry about this when you're
explicitly writing out an
iframe tag.
And sometimes people run into
issues where they explicitly
were using the iframe tag, and
they're trying to talk to it
using JavaScript, but their
code just isn't working.
One thing to debug in that case
is check to see whether
you are setting the
origin parameter.
And if you are, make sure that
it's really set to the full
URL of the host name
for your site.
playerapiid--
this isn't really relevant
anymore.
It's more of a way of using the
older JavaScript API for
identifying your player.
There's a playlist parameter
which is easily confused with
the list parameter.
And it is something that
actually takes in a different
set of values.
The playlist parameter takes
in a list of video IDs.
So this does not have to
be a real playlist, a
[? list that ?] exists
on YouTube.
It doesn't have to be anything
that uploads
from a specific channel.
It could just be a list of any
video IDs that you want.
And it's a way of generating a
dynamic, on-the-fly playlist.
So some use cases where
that might be useful.
There's the rel parameter.
And this controls whether or not
the end screen of a video
will display related
videos or not.
Most folks are familiar with the
fact that once you reach
the end of a YouTube video,
you'll see some configuration
of thumbnails with suggestions
for other videos to play.
We do have the ability to turn
that off if you feel like you
do not want that
on your embeds.
showinfo is something that will
control what is displayed
initially in the
queued states.
There's ways of taking the
default behavior and kind of
toning it down a bit, again,
where you don't see quite as
much before the video starts.
And you can set it to
show info equal
0, if you want that.
showinfo's actually used
in another case.
And that's when you're using
the list player.
And explicitly setting showinfo
equal to 1 will make
it so that there is a list of
queued videos in the playlist
in your list player.
So if we look over here,
this is a case where
showinfo is set to 1.
This is a playlist player that's
loading everything from
Google Developers.
And you'll see, before playback
has even started, you
have this handy thumbnail for
all the videos that are queued
up in the playlist for
the next videos.
It will let you choose what
you want to start with.
So it is actually quite useful
for scenarios where you're
doing the list player.
Start parameter we really
covered before, hand in hand
with the end parameter.
And the last one is the
theme parameter.
This is something similar to
that earlier color parameter
that just lets you change the
default way that the player
looks and gives you some degree
of customization in
that regard.
There are now a couple of
deprecated parameters.
I'm not going to cover those.
They're deprecated
for a reason.
We don't want folks using
them anymore.
I wanted to point out that
there are occasionally--
I don't want to say rumors--
but certain parameters out
there that people pass around
and say, hey, you can use this
player parameter to force HTML5
playback, or use this
player parameter to force
playback in a certain quality
level or something along
those lines.
Those are undocumented
for a reason.
We really do not want people to
use parameters that aren't
explicitly mentioned in the
documentation, partly because
we're not fully committed
to supporting them.
They might sometimes work in
some cases, and they might
stop working at any time
in the future.
So we really don't want people
to build things that rely on
those parameters.
And there's also just cases
where we want control to be in
the hands of the person who's
viewing the embed.
So we want control over the
default playback to really lie
in the person who's using the
web browser and might have
Flash enabled.
Or the default auto quality for
the quality level in many
cases gives the best playback
experience.
So if you don't see something
listed as a supported
parameter, please
don't use it.
And if you do happen to find
some parameters, please don't
complain if they ever break at
some point in the future.
I guess that's the
main takeaway.
That covers the list of all
the supported parameters.
We had a lot of different
web material here.
And be sure to check out the
annotations on the video for
links to everything that
we covered today.
Thanks very much for watching.
And we'll see everybody
next week.
Cheers.